next question in the same vein why do
human beings enjoy the sound of birdsong
mmm I love this question yeah I mean I
think this one is it's let's put it this
way the first order answer is easy we
look for proxies for productivity why do
you find a particular valley beautiful
and another one inhospitable that's
gonna tend to correlate to how likely
you are to be able to find things that
your ancestors might have eaten there or
to grow things that your ancestors might
have grown there so you can imagine that
we could have all kinds of creatures
function it's like an omen that says yes
this is the spot and the yes this is the
spot creature is just one that tends to
be seen in places that are good and
doesn't tend to be seen in places that
are bad so this is probably wrong but
one thing that occurs to me is that one
of the leading hypotheses for why
primates experienced an adaptive
radiation when they did which is you
know the the earliest primates existed
before the KT boundary before Chicxulub
hit what's now the Yucatan about 65
million years ago six million years ago
but that we really expanded quite a bit
afterwards and that this was the
expansion was yes about the opening of
niches as all the non-avian dinosaurs
were now out of the way but one of the
hypotheses also has to do with the
coevolution of angiosperms of flowering
plants and if because primates are
largely like songbirds frugivores or
many songbirds are pollinators as well
but frugivores or insectivorous the
insects themselves being effective
radiated so if all if all of these
things primates were in part Co evolving
along with angiosperms or flowering
plants I suspect although I know much
less about how we've mapped songbird
evolutions of songbirds is a is a real
group its passerines it's a real
evolutionary group I suspect that they
also experienced an adaptive radiation
with angiosperms at flowering plants
because how could they not they're
mostly eating the same stuff so it's
possibly the primates and songbirds are
both sort of mapped on to the same
moment in plant evolution and that if we
were all adaptively radiating at the
same time we would have come to
basically have our aesthetic at a most
fundamental level be that with whom we
were evolving at the same time although
not exactly Co evolving because we
aren't dependent on songbirds for the
most part they aren't big enough to for
us to be eating them and they're mostly
birds and mammals are eating different
seeds of different toxins different
preferences but it could have been a
sort of emerging life at the same time
and such as such a shared vision of
beauty yep I mean there was a lot in
that explanation I like it it's like I
said it's probably wrong because there's
two it hinges on too much at some level
but I'm cautiously betting in favor of
it all right and I would say that you
know we really at the end it's just
basically then songbirds are a proxy for
a productive angiosperm ecosystem in
which plants are paying to have their
seeds distributed yeah that's likely to
be a good place for people yeah yeah I
love that question more questions like
that yeah that's a good one
[Music]